ام
اهلا بكم قتل احد عشر مجلدا واصيب سبعه
وثلاثون في هجوم بسياره ملغمه استهدفت هم
بشمال سيناء صباح الاربعاء من ناحيه اخرى
اصيب اربعه من افراد الشرطه في هجوم شنه
مجهولون على حاجز امني شمال القاهره نتوقف
على الخبر لنناقشه في محورين
ما دلاله تواتر الهجمات على قوات الشرطه
والجيش المصريين منذ انقلاب الثالث من
يوليو تموز الماضي
وما المطلوب لانهاء هذه الهجمات وارساء
علاقه طبيعيه بين قوات الامن ومحيطها في
مصر
في سياق هجمات تستهدف قوات الجيش والشرطه
في مصر منذ الاطاحه بالرئيس المعزول محمد
مرسي شن مجهولون هجوما بالقنبله بقنبله
على حاجز امني شمال القاهره فجر الاربعاء
اصيب فيه بجروح اربعه من عناصر الشرطه
بينهم ضابط برتبه رائد ولم تكن اخبار هجوم
شمال سينا تكتمل حتى حملت الانباء خبر
هجوم اخر اكبر واخطر هذه المره استهدف
حافلات جنود في شمال سيناء و ا وقع بينهم
عشرات القتلى والجرحى
مثل هجمات سيناء الداميه من ورائها ومتى
تتوقف تطل قائمه قتلى قوات الامن المصريه
المستهدفه في شبه الجزيره المضطربه تضاف
الى ال قائمه اسماء ما لا يقل عن عشره
جنود مصريين اغتيلوا في هجوم انتحاري
استهدف حافلتهم على الطريق المؤدي الى
معبر رفح الحدودي واصيب ما لا يقل عن خمسه
وثلاثين اخرين بجروح متفاوته رد الجيش بشن
حمله مداهمات في منطقه الشيخ زويد منطقه
ارتبط اسمها بالهجمات الانتحاريه وملاحقه
الجيش من يصفهم بالارهابيين المسلحين
اتسعت رقعه العنف وتصاعدت في سيناء منذ
الانقلاب على الرئيس محمد مرسي في يوليو
الماضي وفق بيان رسمي قتل منذ ذلك التاريخ
واربعه وثلاثين عنصرا من افراد الامن في
سيناء وحدها بالاضافه الى عدد من القتلى
في باقي المحافظات المصريه اسوء وجو ان
كان ذلك الذي حدث في اغسطس الماضي وادى
الى مقتل خمسه وعشرين شرطي في رفح العنف
المتصاعد في ارض الكنانه شهد تحولا خطيرا
بعد السيد في موكب وزير الداخليه بسياره
مفخخه في الخامس من سبتمبر الماضي تزداد
المخاوف من استمرار هذه الدوامه وال ظهور
تنظيمات مسلحه اخرى ب تسميات مختلفه غير
انصار بيت المقدس
وهو التنظيم الذي تبنى عددا من الهجمات
بينها محاوله اغتيال وزير الداخليه
ومقتل ضابط امن كبير خلال هذا الشهر
التطورات الاخيره تبرهن مره اخرى ان
العمليات العسكريه لم تكثر شوكه المناوئين
للمؤسسات الامنيه في البلاد وفي جون
سياسيين محتقن الى اقصى الحدود لتبدو
القبضه الامنيه هي الحل الوحيد الانجع
لتحقيق الاستقرار قبل تكون لغه الحوار في
الوقت الراهن هي المفضله لدى السلطه
الحاكمه لانقاذ البلد من الانزلاق نحو
هويه الفوضى العنف الاعمى قد تم اح كما
اخرى تاخذ حوار عاقل يجمع كل ابناء الوطن
الواحد في الاخير حول تتامل الدنيا الى
الاماني مفقود
معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في الاستوديو
الكاتب الصحفي والقنديل من باريس اللواء
ياسين سند الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
ومن القاهره عبر سكايب اللواء عادل سليمان
مدير منتدى الحوار الاستراتيجي للدراسات
الدفاع اهلا بضيوفنا جميعا نبدا من
القاهره والحدث هناك سيد اللواء عادل
سليمان بتقدير كيف يفهم هذا الازدياد في
اعداد العمليات ضد الجيش والامن
هذا الامر واضح تمام الوضوح
اما الخلايا الكامله في سماء سواء ثالث
خلايا الثلاثين بهديه او خلايا بفكر
القاعده المتشدد او العصابات
دوليه او المنظمه الموجوده في بناء التي
تعمل في طرق تهريب البشر والمخدرات
وما الى ذلك ما بين اه افريقيا ومصر
اسرائيل وكل هذه العناصر التي تهدف الى اه
عدم
الاستقرار في منطقه اثناء وتستغل كل
الظهور في الاضطراب السياسي في مصر لتمارس
هذا النشاط لفرض وبدها تمكنها من اما
توفير ملاذات امنه او ممارسه اعمالها ال
اه
مخالفه للقانون الاجراميه مثل عصابات
تهريب هذه الخلايا تخوض
كما سخيه مع القوات المسلحه
مصر السلطه حربه طبيعه حرب العصابات
هذه الحرب لا يمكن حسمها اه بسهوله لا
يمكن ان توضع لها نهايه
الحروب التقليديه الجيوش النظاميه عاده اه
تعاني من استنزاف كبير اه كل الامر تتصور
انها عليها كما تصدر على البيانات
العسكريه
فيها لاعلام خاليه من الارهاب اه تفادي
الجماعات عمليات ارهابيه جديده اشد
الضحايا للاسف بناء اه الذين اه قدم معهم
للقوات المسلحه فتره التجديد للدفاع عن
الوطن وحمايه اربعين بين
قتلى ضحايا هذه ال ال الحرب التي يمكن ان
تتحول الى حرب سياسيه تستهدف
جهود القوات المسلحه حرب وجود الشرطه
والامن اه ولا يمكن ان تصل الى اه نتيجه
حاكمه والتقارب عديده ليس فقط عندنا في
دول كثيره لابد من
النيه
سياسيه
تنمويه مختلفه للتعامل مع هذه الجماعات
ولكن اشرت لو سليمان الى ان هذه الجماعات
هي خليط من من خلايا جهاديه وعصابات منظمه
وغيرها هنا نسال لوا ياسين سنه ما الذي
يمكن ان يجمع هذا الخليط
لاستهداف رجال الامن والشرطه على وجه
التحديد وليس ايه اهداف اخرى
مساء الخير اولا
الفريقين والمشاهدين اه
الموقف في النهار دا الحقيقه مختلف شويا
اه طبعا القوات المسلحه بتاخذ خبرات من
الواقع السابقه اللي كان فيها الناس اللي
انعملت في العريش وختام يوم والدم
الاوتوبيس اه كان فيه تسرب للاخبار القوات
المسلحه للمرادي كان اه ماشين اربعه ان
بعض مفاصل خمسين متر قدامهم عربيه الحمايه
ولكن اه بعد ممارسه عربيه الحمايه كان فيه
اه عربيه ثانيه مفخخه انفجرت بعد
بالموت بالحب لاسلكي فاصابت الاوتوبيس ال
في النص وبعدين طبعا المؤسسات الاخرى اه
حصل الكاس وال اجازه
استشهد 11 جندى وفي سبعه حالتهم خطره من
الجرحى موجودين فى المعادى فى الاسماعيليه
ولكن اه وباقي طرحه واحد وثلاثين واحد ال
ال ال ال الحاله بعد كده دي الوقتي بيحصل
تنشيط كامل في المنطقه علشان خاطر يتم
القضاء انا قلت قبل كده في لقاء سابق مع
حضرتك انه ال اه تقريبا ثمانيه وتسعين
المائه من العمليات بتاعه سيما
الحاجات البسيطه الموجوده هي الناس اللي
لسه ما زالت موجوده بين الاهالي وطبعا
القوات المسلحه ما بتحاول الشتاء من اي
حاجه يكون فيها ابرياء ضحايا
بتحاول تكون موضوعيه في الاداء وعلشان كان
كمان القبائل اه انا بعتقد انه مش ال مش
الاسلوب الامني هو الوحيد ال الاسلوب
الاخر الافضل دلوقتي ان احنا نستفيد
بالناس اللي هي الجهات اللي كانوا عملوا
المراجعات زي الشيخ ناجح ابراهيم والشيخ
نبيل
يعني يعني هذا يتعلق
في مساله ال ال المعالجات التي يمكن ان
تاتي
بعد غيابه يعني بعد ان اتفقت يعني حتى
نبقى في ال في الحدث في حد ذاته
نسال اه السيد وائل قنديل اه ال ال القضيه
لا تتعلق فقط بس انه لان هناك كما ان هناك
هجومات على مراكز الشرطه هناك حتى
اغتيالات منطقا تمثل الذي اه اه تعرض له
المقدم محمد مبروك وهو ضابط في جهاز الامن
ومسؤول عن التحقيقات مع اه انصار مرسي كما
ذكرت وكاله الانباء هل تعتقد بان هذه
الاهداف منتقاه بعنايه
انا يعني انا يلفت النظر في كل ذلك
التوقيتات عديده للغايه
وتداعيات هذه الاخبار اعقد بكثير اه يعني
بعد اغتيال ا ضابط امن الدوله ثم اه اه
الهجوم اليوم اولا دعنا يعني اه ن نع الى
الشعب المصري هؤلاء الشهداء الضحايا
الابرياء يعني وهذا عمل يعني دينه
باعتباره العمل الارهابيه بكل ما للكلمه
من معنى ولكن دعنا اه
نتصور الموقف قبل شهر او اكثر عندما بدات
هذه الهجمه الموسعه الشامله تحت شعار
الحرب على الارهاب وتجفيف منابع الارهاب
وفرض السيطره على الارهاب عندما تضرب في
المكان ذاته
اه اه في غضون يعني مع فاصل زمني لا
يتجاوز اسابيع و بالطريقه ذاتها و يتم
استيراد مجموعه من الضحايا الابرياء مره
اخرى فلا شك ان هذا يكشف عن خلل لا لا
يستطيع احد ان يتحدث هنا عن اداء مهني او
اداء موضوعي او اداء كبير يعني ان توجه
الضربه مره اخرى رغم كل هذه التحذيرات
ورغم ما سبق هذه العمليه من اعلان اه
دعائيه كبير عن ان هناك مصالحات مع رؤوس
القبائل في هذه المناطق وان هناك صفحه
جديده وهو فهذا يؤكد مره اخرى ان هناك
تقصيرا امنيا اه اه اه يعني برسم القياده
العسكريه والقياده الامنيه التي تعمل في
هذه المنطقه هذا خذنا مره اخرى الى ان
المؤسسه العسكريه الجيش المصري الان منشغل
بقضايا ما كان له ان يتدخل فيها يعني
ملاحقه فتيات على كورنيش الاسكندريه
ملاحقه طلاب الازهر كل هذه العمليات نزول
الجيش الى الشارع
والكلام بالضروره اذا ركزت على القلب على
الشارع على الداخل او على اخص خصائص
الداخل فلابد ان ستكون هناك ثغرات
من الجيش المصري ما شاء الله جيش الجيش
كبير من انشغاله ب ما ذكرت لن يضعف
بالضروره من حلقات اخرى موجوده على
الميدان ولها ولها مهام عسكريه وانا اريد
تفسيرا ان تضرب هذه المؤسسه اه في في
المكان ذاته مع فوارق زمنيه بسيطه للغايه
بالاليات بصرف النظر عن هذه المره سياره
مفخخه اه اه او المره الاخرى كان هجوما
بالرشاشات او بالمدافع او او في النهايه
هناك استهداف واضح وتحدي و اصطياد لجنود
مصريين ابرياء يتم حظهم بهذه ال الم في
المكان ذاته
اذا اذا وضعنا ان يعني هناك كلام كبير جدا
عن حرب
والتنسيق مع الجانب الاسرائيلي وتنسيق مع
الاداره الامريكيه واه واستحضار كل القوى
ال المصريه وسلاح الاعلام وكل ذلك نجيش
المشاعر ل اننا نخوض حربا مقدسه وسنقدم
على الارهاب قضاء مبرما ثم الوفاء بهذه
الضربه ولكن حتى هذه الحرب يعني على
الارهاب اه عندما اه اه يشير اللواء عادل
سليمان وهنا اعود اليه في القاهره عندما
يشير بان ال ال ال الاطراف هي خلايا نائمه
او خلايا جهاديه او عصابات منظمه في
النهايه هل تعتقد بان البعد هو سياسي اكثر
منه اجرامي في في الحالات هذه الاخيره على
البعض مختلف حقيقه الامر
هناك اجرامي فينا نستطيع ان ننكر
سجله دوليا واستطاع معروفه مع الدراسه من
منظمات دوليه كثيره في البشر افريقيا
بالكامل الى معسكرات هذا داخل الاراضي
الاسرائيليه في بيريز او في ايدي ومعروفه
مسلمه دوليا وعائدها المليارات وهذا امر
جديد الخطوره لم ينتبه اليها هناك ايضا
بعد ان فيها بعض عندما عاد هناك توزيع
لحاله الاضطراب السياسيه التي تسود
استغلال لها من كل هذه العناصر كل من يسعى
الى هذه ليست
واحده
ولكن كل ما يجري مصلحه ما عندما تكون
الامور مضطربه
شديد الاهميه وهو قلب المشكله والى الدماء
التي تسير على ارض هذا الطريق طريق ربع
اه
الجيش حتى
القناه الطريق معروف
الكثيره تقع عليه
بالامس الطريقه كمصادر عبر
بالمنجزات
هذه النقطه هذه النقطه التي اشار اليها
قبل قليل السيد قنديل يعني وهي اه لافت
للانتباه يعني
الذين يقومون بهذا العمل هؤلاء الاطراف
متغير
تغير في هذه المنطقه
اثنين وثلاثه واربعه
ان يتم تطوير في تامين الامن والحراسه
البلاد والسبعينات
الدوليه امام الافراد هناك رسائل
تكنولوجيه هذه الطرق
هناك الكثير
ومعدات متطوره
محاربه
يقتلون
الطريق وكانهم
مناطق ولكن ولكن اللافت اللافت على كل
سليمان اللافت ان هناك اجماع وطني مصري
على ادانه كل اه اه ما جرى ولهذا نريد ان
نعرف بعد الفاصل الى اي مدى يمكن ان تكون
هناك امكانيه لارساء علاقه طبيعيه بين
قوات الامن المصريه والجيش
المناخ السياسي المتوتر
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد ما زلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها ابعاد و دلالات
تواتر الهجمات في الفتره الاخيره في مصر
على عناصر ومواقع الجيش والشرطه اللواء
ياسين سنه في في باريس اشرت قبل قليل الى
ما سميتها تمشيط
اه ولكن ا اشرت في نفس الوقت الى ضروره ان
لا ينزعج الاهالي من ردود الفعل ال
الامنيه على ما يجري برايك ما الذي يمكن
ان ان ان تقوم به مؤسسه الجيش ومؤسسه
الامن لمعالجه هذا الوضع دون ان تزيد ه
تفاقما بعلاقه ربما اه تصبح اه اه اكثر
عدائيه بين هذه المجموعات الامنيه والجيش
و اه اه ال اه المجموعات التي تستهدفها
اه يعني لازم اوضح نقطه مهمه اوي ل
لو عاد ال اه الاخوان ال اه اللي بيحصل اه
فيه تقدم بيحصل ما فيش جدال انه العمال
بيتعلق ويسيطر عليها سيما بيسيطر عليها او
البول هو المشكله كلها ان عدد ال ال
الاعداء كثيرين يعني المعادين لمصر كثيرين
لا لا لا نستبعد اسرائيل من العمله لا
نستبعد امريكا لا نستبعد طبعا ال ال ال ال
وعادل
الاتجار بالبشر لا نستبعد المهربين الحشيش
ولا السلاح ولا كل لكن انا اللي بدي اقوله
الطرف اللي عنده عقيده اللي هو معتقد
تماما انه هو الوحيد اللي بيمثل الاسلام
هذه مشكله الحقيقيه الان اللي عنده عقيده
رايح يموت ب ب ب استشهاد وحاسس النوع داخل
اللجنه انه عايز الحقيقه تكاثف من اطراف
عديده واناشد ال ال ال المساجد بتاعه
السلفيين والاخوان
الازهر بتعلم ال ال ال وزاره الاوقاف كلهم
يدعو للناس في في المساجد اه ايام الجمعه
في المساجد يدعو لهم بالهدايه وانهم
يعودوا الى الدين القويم الصحيح الوسطي
المعتدل وزي ما قلت في الاول وحضرتك
تعطيني نستخدم الناس الجهاديين لانهم على
علم ودول ال الفكر افضل حاجه للاحتكاك
الفكري اقوى كثير من السلاح فالناس دي
ممكن ان يعاد معاهم في ندوات بحيث يتعود
المفاهيم عن اه هذا الاداء اللي معتقدين
عقيده عقيده راسخه انهم بيعملوا في سبيل
الله
اسمح لي مره اخرى يعني طالما ان الصوره
ليست واضحه من هم هؤلاء الجهاديين اصحاب
عقيده مثل ما قلت ما الذي يجعلنا نلجا الى
هذا الاسلوب دون غيره اذا لم نكن متاكدين
من الذي يفعل ذلك
لا متاكدين لانه واحد مجموعه زي انصار ال
ال البيت المقدس سيبين بيت المقدس خالص هو
بيحاربوا في مصر انه انت شايف المقدم
مبروك اللي تلوه على الشعب المشاهد في
الاداء قاعه الاخوان وكان مسكي المواضيع
بتاعته وكذلك ال ال ال الناس النهارده
ضربت في الكمين بتاع الموقف عبود
العربيه
اه
وخلافه كثير يعني
يعني بعد اذنك في هذه الحاله اذا كنا نرجح
السيد وائل قنديل ان يكون ان رجح ان من
يقف هو بالدرجه الاساسيه مجموعات جهاديه
او تكفيريه او اه اه اه تسمى ما تسمى
لتقديره ال القضيه في النهايه مرتبطه ب جو
سياسي في البلد ولا نستطيع ان نعالجها
معالجه امنيه خارج السياق السياسي لكي
نعالج هذه القضيه لابد ان نبتعد اولا عن
فكره الاستثمار السياسي لهذه القضيه
لمواصله الاستقطاب والاقصاء والاباده
لفصيل سياسى مصرى معين او لا
اه مثل هذه القضايا لن تحل بالدعاء في
المساجد في حقيقه الامر اذا كنا نتحدث عن
عمليات احترافيه تمارسها مجموعات منظمه
بصرف النظر عن هويه هذه المجموعات بالرد
عليها لابد ان يكون اداء امنيا محترفا
بعيدا عن هذا الطرف والاسترخاء اذا كنا
ندين الارهاب ضد الجنود البسطاء في سيناء
بالضروره لابد ان ندين ارهاب الدوله
وارهاب النظام ضد المصريين في رابعه
العدويه وفي اماكن اخرى انت تمارس الارهاب
على شعبك ثم تريد قاعده جماهيريه او قاعده
شعبيه لكي تدعم ك في الحرب على الارهاب في
سيناء هذه المفارقه
اسمح لي لا لا علاقه بين الامرين
ان اه اه ان طالما اي دوله لا يمكن ان
تتعامل الا بالعصا الغليظه مع جماعات
مسلحه مع جماعات مسلحه وليس مواطنين
متظاهرين معتصمين نساء واطفال هذا ارهاب
ايضا لابد ان يدان كمان
علاقه سبب ومسبب في في هذه المساله
بالضروره و اضف الى ذلك ان فكره الرجوع
الى جماعه انصار بيت المقدس هذا اختراع
امني هذه الجماعه وهميه يبدو انها اخترعت
لكي تسند اليها كل اوجه القصور والفشل
والاهمال لكي تنسب الى هذه الجماعه نحن لا
نرى اصلا ولا اظن ان هذه الجماعه فجاه مع
اعلان ما يسمى بالحرب على الارهاب في
سيناء لم نكن نسمع عنها قبل ذلك التاريخ
وبالتالي هي حاضره طول الوقت انا يعني
يعني عفوا اذا كانت اخترعت ايه مصلحه في
من اخترع ما الذي يريده انه يريد ان يكرس
مقوله انه في سيناء يحارب يقود حربا ضد
الارهاب وضد المؤامرات الدوليه وبالتالي
اذا في هذه الحاله يكون هو الذي يفعلها
بالغين وبالتالي كل اجراءات قمعيه غير
انسانيه ارهابيه ضد المصريين في الداخل هي
مبرره لانني اخوض حربا مقدسه لكي احكم على
الحدود لفت النظر انه في ظل هذه التفجيرات
المتعاقبه يعني اغتيال ضابط امن الدوله ثم
هذا التفجير في موقف السيارات ثم عمليات
سيناء بعضها بسويعات بتقرر الماده بتحصين
وزير الدفاع كما طلب ل دوره او دورتين
رئاسيتين
يحصل منصب وزير الدفاع يعينه المجلس
الاعلى للقوات المسلحه ويستمر الاداره او
دورتين وهذا هو مطلب وزير الدفاع الحالي
يعني لا لا نريد ان نستبعد كل ذلك لا نريد
ايضا ان نستبعد فكره ال العنصر الخارجي
يعني لماذا في اسرائيل تماما رغم ان ال
يعني هناك ما يبدو ان هناك تنسيق او
تناغما للغايه بين سلطه الانقلاب في مصر
وبين قيادات العدو الصهيوني بدليل ان
لقاءا امنيا عقده في مطلع اكتوبر الماضي
عاموس جلعاد و و افرايم سنيه وخبراء
امنيين المصريين من المنتمين الى معسكر
الانقلاب هذا يعني في امبريال كوليدج في
اول اكتوبر الماضي لا نريد ان نستبعد يعني
لا لا يغيب عنها شبح مثلا التفجير الذي
جرى في الضاحيه الجنوبيه في بيروت اه اول
امس يعني كل هذه عناصر سيناء معروف منذ
البدايه انها مرتع لكل ال ال اجهزه
المخابرات وقوه
تمارس عربده وتمارس ومع ذلك نحن يعني
عندما خرج وقالوا حربا على الارهاب قلنا
سننتظر
تاتي الضربه في نفس المكان بنفس ال اليه
مع سقوط البرد فهذا يعني انهم مقصرون
ومؤمنون اذا اذا في هذه الحاله ونختم ب
اللواء عادل سليمان في القاهره ب ب بهذا
التحليل اذا ما اه سيرتها سليمان لا يمكن
لنا ان نعالج ما يجري الى معالجه سياسيه
والاف لن يحصل اي شيء
نحن في حاجه الى رؤيه سياسيه
مائه تنمويه مختلفه تماما نحن كثير على
قواعد ومناهج قديمه في التعامل مع كل هذه
القضايا حتى الان منذ العمليه العمليه
مجلس الوزراء التي يصرح بانه
على الارهاب وكل هذه البيانات والبنات
العسكريه
واحد نستطيع منتمي تنظيم او لاي دماء كلها
اذا
وقلناها اه مبادرات لا تحمل على مضمون لا
بد من اعاده النظر في صالح هذا الوطن رؤيا
امنيه رؤيه سياسيه اولا كيف نتعامل مع من
البناء ظهير القضائي في لقوات الامن ولا
اي عمل حمى نحن لم نستطع مقاومه العمليات
الارهابيه في بدايه
الا عندما توعدت عندما
قوات وعناصر شكرا جزيلا لك
من القاهره شكرا لضيفنا من باريس اللواء
ياسين سند ضيفنا هنا في الاستوديو الكاتب
الصحفي وائل قنديل في امان الله
ام